hello reject nation happy Super Bowl
Sunday kicking it off today with
Jurassic world falling Kingdom bugle
baby the John and I are we are enjoying
the Superbowl here at the computer today
totally I know which sports team played
the most sports thus far got a lot of
crap for saying this movie is a dumb
monster movie no no after this gritty
film the y'all missed the parts where I
said I actually enjoy this movies no but
whatever this is watch this was a little
scarier
[Music]
whoa I said this girl's home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the island hey he was down there
[Music]
whoa just give away that death oh yeah
boy that death that's for sure okay also
I think this trailer is better than the
last one we got yeah it definitely
hooked me with more stuff and it did
bring in a more scary imposing vibe yeah
I'll give him that
yeah lot last trailer was kind of like I
get they're trying to give scary
imposing but I find it still pretty
silly and while there's some silly stuff
to be had here I bought the tone a
little bit more I think and watching
this specific trailer I feel like there
could be something eerie about going
back to the carcass of Jurassic world
and having them try them and like rescue
the last of the dinosaurs that they can
save and saying they built a new
dinosaur other genetically others are
all gathered around and stuff yeah and
apparently it's it's gonna drastic Park
to that [ __ ] and it's gonna be in the
suburbs or something that gets me
concerned that gets me worried I mean
although if the lost world had the tone
of Jurassic world I think I would have
bought the whole t-rex showing up in San
Diego or San Francisco wherever it goes
in that movie at the end more because at
first I was watching asleep I gots
pretty scary a little girl with a big
old dinosaur and it really looks like
blue is gonna be this the sidekick to
Chris Pratt in this movie who he just
like getting blues like a little Pokemon
this time yeah they're hooking me with
this weird blend of I don't know if I
think this looks good or or really
misguided but I kind of want to see the
outcome cuz they do also have a chance
to make a new impression cuz I'm not a
big fan of the first movie honestly like
I thought it was fun and the dinosaur
stuff was cool weirdly I liked that they
didn't just clean house and get new
characters and I hope I like them yeah
this well I like I like the
ridiculousness do I think it's not as
good as Jurassic Park of course
not by now yeah I mean there's even
ridiculous up here but he's inside of
the T Rexes little tiny prison and he
manages to just ridiculous and it
totally takes away from the world of
reality that the first Jurassic Park set
up in terms of its rules in Jurassic
world universe let's find a little vibe
of Jurassic Park two and three and
Jurassic world in this so is yeah like
it's majorly departing from what we know
I'm actually surprised I took it to the
you know off the island where the
dinosaurs are and some people's homes
and stuff because that was the biggest
upset with the lost world to know that
the part two to this is doing that I
hope they play this out better because
that already pissed people off enough in
part two so I'm wondering if that will
go over well here but right now I mean
it looks like a little bit more intense
the cinematography and the way it's
captured looks more like a horror movie
I feel like there's gonna be a fun
monster horror movie well that's only
trailer number one for the Superbowl
today guys you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up and yes we got more
videos coming today become a patron Jack
today it'll help out